MIT is origami Club which we call Oregon
it is a student-run organization where
folders can come from the surrounding
area and the entire MIT community is
welcome to come and just learn to fold
something new or try something they've
already done before come and show
something else I first saw origami in
like fourth grade and from then on I was
just like infatuated with it and I
always wanted to you know learn how to
transfer paper into cool objects and
then when I came to MIT I found out
there was this club for it and it was
just like amazing coming to it and
learning everyone's like advanced skill
levels and things like that so origami
is basically ancient Japanese art paper
folding or already stands for folding
and call me the where that comes from is
for paper it's been practiced for
hundreds of years and keeps getting more
advanced and more geometrically
alone young kids do come into our club
and all of them actually are varying
degrees of experience is some of them
were our beginners who are just learning
how to forward grains for instance or
other simple model but some of them are
really ambitious and incumbent and they
try to learn how to design their own
origami I've been doing origami since I
was five
well we try to help those who are still
learning how to fold and for those
shortened origami design we talked to
him did and really encouraged them a lot
of people are intimidated by origami
they think central and mighty students
that you know everything's super
advanced we use all this math stuff but
really anyone can do it I think it's
because MIT said like the challenges
also anything that someone else had done
before all right they feel like they can
do it too that was my first attempt but
I couldn't get it together so I made a
larger one and than I what not once I
understood everything together normally
we give you a diagram so when they get
to partitioning a wolf to ask for help
like ask you question but MIT student no
I did I just keep added at vitam cells
like it's work out it's like okay does
it look at it say okay I'll get I can
get this I don't I can do this myself I
highly encourage anyone who even if
you've never hold it before to just stop
by
and I don't want to do it for you
because you might find out how much you
love it and then just keep coming back
Oh